okay so Canadian professor Jordan
Peterson has claimed for a long time
that he's not political and not a sort
of a spouse er of right-wing ideas and
yet he recently appeared at extremists
outrageous right-wing Christian Liberty
University this is the evangelical
school that has a policy of no
premarital sex on campus no private
interactions between members of the
opposite sex on campus it was founded by
the late Jerry Falwell who claimed that
abortionists and feminists and gay
people were to blame for 9/11
that's where Jordan Peterson appeared on
a panel with a bunch of right-wing
religious nuts to engage I guess in a
discussion of ideas or something just as
a reminder in an interview with
political last year Peterson said what
he does is not political even though it
obviously is
he says it's merely psychological I
guess like the psychology of why a bogus
caricature of Marxism and post-modernism
is terrible for everyone and how the bad
bad left wanting equality of outcome
which we don't is bad bad bad for
everyone it's not political remember you
can't say that it's merely psychological
most people know this is bogus and then
he appears at Liberty University and
I'll play some clips here he is saying
very non-political stuff that sounds
exactly like right-wing stuff but it
isn't like for example here he praises
David Nasser who is the senior vice
president for spiritual development at
Liberty University for how great his
opening was and how great it is to speak
at Liberty University which isn't
cynical and toxic like other
universities I by the way I loved your
opening it's so nice to come to a
gathering like this it isn't
characterized by a like a toxic under
structure of cynicism you know I see
that in so many universities and it's
really corrosive and I hate to see it
among young people because well first of
all you haven't earned your cynicism
that would be the first thing but second
well second because it's so corrosive
and it's such a catastrophe to go to
Institutes of higher learning and see
that what's being developed in young
people when they're first starting to
open themselves up to the world is a
cynicism that tells them before they
know anything that life is a terrible
catastrophe
Liberty University which is an
outrageous right-wing University that
pretends we're living in the 1800s is
the one University that Jordan Peterson
has found that's not toxic or cynical
the problem is that without critical
thinking with science blended with
religion people end up in a fantasy
world where they're not even able to
reflect in a way that gets them to
question the structures of society and
the status quo that's what he's
identifying at Liberty Liberty
University and this is a right wing idea
that he's espousing but again remember
he's not political he just says the one
University doing it right is one of the
craziest right-wing Christian
universities in the country if not the
world and I know his supporters will say
David his appearance at Liberty it's not
political he's doing his psychology
he'll do it anywhere people want to have
him he's engaging in debate and all of
that stuff Liberty University wants him
there for a reason and this is so funny
by the way David Nasser this this guy I
told you about who's on the panel he's
part of Liberty University says hey I
went to Barnes & Noble and the employees
were all talking about how it's all men
buying your book normally women come in
and buy more books than men but it's men
who were coming in and buying your books
which is so funny because this is one of
those allegations that has dogged
Peterson for a while that he's appealing
overwhelmingly disproportionately to men
and he's had to sort of handle it in
different ways and even the guy at
Liberty University mentions it take a
look so many of our cities
just been impacted by you over three
million books have been sold I walked
into the Barnes & Noble the other day
and you know you're doing well when
you've gotten good product placement in
a book right in the front but you know
you're doing really well where they have
stacks and stacks of your book behind
the cash register just to keep up with
the demand and the young lady that was
there started talking to me a little bit
and then this other employee came up and
he said it's been interesting so many
men are buying this book typically women
are a lot more frequent you know
shoppers at a bookstore these days but
he said this book is just taking over
the world listen it's not bad if mostly
men like Jordan Peterson's book and it's
not bad if he's basically a right-wing
actor it's fine just don't pretend to be
apolitical don't pretend to be not
right-wing don't pretend that your
audience isn't mostly male just embrace
it explain why it is as he has taken to
doing more recently and that's who you
are and then he goes into the
post-modernism or as he says
post-modernism at universities
specifically post modernist Marxism
which is just not really a problem and
then he ridicules the idea of a
judeo-christian Western patriarchy not
not political not right-wing of course
inside the philosophical confines of the
post modernist movement as it manifests
itself in universities currently is that
it's very very important to understand
this because otherwise you don't know
what you're facing there is no debate
about free speech because for the post
modernists especially the ones that that
have a Marxist leaning there is no such
thing as free speech because you see in
order for there to be free speech there
have to be sovereign individuals not
mere members of a group and in the
postmodernist world there are no
sovereign individuals that's a that's a
judeo-christian oppressive Western
patriarchal arbitrary presupposition
it's your group identity
that's its primary and paramount you
don't have ideas and thoughts you have
what you've been socially conditioned to
believe and the exchange of ideas is
nothing but a power game that's played
between groups of people who are
opposing each other for predominance on
the world stage that's it and so it's
not a debate about the value of free
speech that that's a trivial debate in
some sense it's a debate about whether
free speech itself actually constitutes
a genuine phenomenon I would never deny
that wacky people exist on all sides of
the political spectrum but these are
right-wing caricatures of the left why
can't we all just admit it and deal with
Peterson as a partisan actor
meanwhile the non-political
non-religious in' so impressed the
american conservative publication with
his appearance at liberty university
that they've now written up a piece
about him and his mission and just how
great and wonderful he is he's not
political he's not right-wing just be
accountable okay I just wish the
right-wing heroes would be accountable I
have no problem with the right saying
this is our hero and they're saying it
and that's fine let's just acknowledge
that that's what these people are and
not live in this fantasy world of Jordan
Peterson as the non-political unbiased
observer of society we know that that's
not the case let's just stop pretending
we will all be better off if that's what
we do make sure you're following the
david pakman show on instagram at david
pakman show follow me while you're there
at David Pakman one of the day's
sponsors is privacy dot-com slash Pakman
which is a free service that I myself
use really useful in many different ways
takes just a few seconds to link your
debit card to privacy calm then you can
create virtual credit cards that are
linked directly to your bank account and
you use those virtual credit card
numbers to buy things online which
protects your actual debit card
so that it's not spread all over the
Internet and one of the best things
about it is how their mobile app and
browser extensions for Chrome and
Firefox make it really easy to use let's
say for example that I'm signing up for
a david pakman show membership in the
credit card number field I already see
the privacy comm icon I just click it
choose which of my virtual credit cards
I want to use and the credit card number
expiration date and security code are
automatically entered I can put in any
zip code I want and I'm done and if you
try to use my credit card number that
you just saw on the screen it doesn't
matter because I've already deleted that
virtual card and that's the beauty of
privacy comm there are a ton of
advantages to using a free service like
this for example you can sign up for as
many free trials as you want then just
delete the virtual credit card you used
and never worry about getting charged
for it it protects you from getting
hacked it protects you when companies
are hacked which happens all the time it
is all completely free all you have to
do is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
they're giving everyone in our audience
$5 towards your first purchase when you
sign up using that link